und da geht es eigentlich um die
Atomkraft also ich will das mal relativ
kurz machen damit wir uns dann auch
richtig schön streiten können was mich
seit einiger Zeit
ärgert ist die Tabuisierung eines Themas
alles anderes hier inzwischen kein Tabu
mehr weder die Bundeswehr Aufrüstung
dringend überfällig viel zu lange
verschlampt worden von einer großen
Koalition
auch ein Tabuthema das so langsam fällt
ist dass man immer mehr Klimaschutz
machen muss was ja im Kern auch richtig
ist nur wenn ich den Ukraine Konflikt
sehe wenn ich sehe dass wir im Grunde
entweder selbst ein Energie embargo
machen müssen weil wir so unter Druck
geraten dass das die anderen von uns als
Beweis von Solidarität fordern oder aber
der Herr im Kreml einfach mal sagt ich
lass mich doch nicht von dem Western
jetzt hier vorführen das drehe ich den
Geldhahn zu dann haben wir Probleme mit
der Energieversorgung
in einer solchen Situation
einfach zu sagen wir diskutieren über
alles auch über eine Verlängerung der
Laufzeiten für Kohlekraftwerke aber
überhaupt nicht über eine Verlängerung
der Laufzeit dieser letzten drei
Atommeiler vielleicht auch noch eine
Wiederbelebung der gerade Ende des
Jahres stillgelegten meiner weil wir die
Stromversorgung und dafür gilt ja nur
die Kernenergie dadurch deutlich
absichern können das was wir dann noch
an Kohle und Gas brauchen halt in die
anderen Prozesse zu machen ich weiß auch
mit Kerne die kann ich kein Auto fahren
und ich kann auch meine Heizung nicht
betreiben aber ich kann die
Stromversorgung weitgehend sichern über
das Maß hinaus und muss nicht umschalten
jetzt kommt das Argument kenne ich auch
Brennelemente also selbst und wenn ich
mal unterstelle wir kriegen die nicht so
schnell die neuen die man braucht selbst
wenn man jetzt sagt okay dann drosseln
wir
die Nutzung der Kernenergie im Sommer
und ersetzen das durch Kohle
dann habe ich ja immer noch die Chance
dass ich in dem Winter wo es drauf
ankommen wo jeder merkt wenn es kalt
wird in der Wohnung und wo ich keinen
Strom mehr habe um irgendwas im
Licht zu haben und dergleichen dann kann
ich das Nutzen ganz abgesehen davon dass
ich ohnehin glaube dass man sehr wohl
Brennelemente besorgen kann wenn man es
denn will und die Politik es will wenn
die etwas will kann sie ja anderes sehr
deutlich machen mich ärgert das darüber
nicht diskutiert wird weil es ein grüne
DNA ist und man wohl die Sorge hat mein
Gott den Grünen wird jetzt eh schon so
viel zugemutet da kann man nicht nur das
es geht um mich nicht Miss zu verstehen
nicht darum dass die nächsten zehn Jahre
Atommeiler laufen es geht mir um diese
Überbrückungszeit in der jetzigen durch
den Ukraine Krieg und die
Unberechenbarkeit von Wladimir Putin
entstandene Situation und letztendlich
zu sagen das brauchen wir nicht halte
ich für leichtfertig ja ich habe einen
gewissen autorenstolz denn die Kraft sie
haben die nämlich damals genehmigt die
drei die sie jetzt genannt haben habe
ich mit meiner Unterschrift genehmigt
und ich habe damals
meinen Freund Genscher der
Parteivorsitzende mal gefragt kann ich
das machen meine Fachleute
Reaktorsicherheit im Innenministerium
haben sehr sorgfältig das vorbereitet
das ist ein war ein Konvoi die sind nach
einem gleichen baummuster genehmigt
worden wird jede Schraube genehmigt so
also ganz pingelig und da hat er mir
gesagt Herr Baum wenn sie das nicht
können dann müssen sie alle laufenden
Atome sofort abstellen denn die die sie
jetzt auf dem Tisch haben zu Genehmigung
sind noch wesentlich sicherer als die
früheren also sie sind alle sicher aber
im Grunde müssen sie jetzt sich fragen
steigen Sie aus der wenn Sie nicht
wollen wenn Sie das nicht wollen steigen
Sie aus der Atom Energie aus und ich
kann jetzt nicht ja Bremer sagen wie man
die jetzt wieder tüchtigen kann was ich
damals noch bedauert habe dass wir aus
der ganzen Technologie ausgestiegen es
gibt ja mehr die ganze Technologie geht
es darüber hinweg und da sind wir
ausgestiegen in einer Paniksituation
ich habe große Anstrengung unternommen
die Entsorgung sicherzustellen die bis
heute nicht sichergestellt ich habe
dieser Tage mal eine Regierungserklärung
nachgelesen die ich 1979 abgegeben habe
da habe ich an die Länder appelliert
doch ein Endlager zur Führung zu stellen
der einzige der das gemacht hat bei Herr
Albrecht ist auf die Schnauze gefahren
mit Gorleben dann sind wir nach Bayern
haben unsere Augen sich nach Bayern
gerichtet keiner wollte das bis heute
der einzige der das mal ehrlich
angesprochen hat war ja Habeck das
gehört nämlich auch dazu und das obszöne
an der ganzen Sache ist in Knüpfer in
Zeiten der knabbert kaufen wir Atomstrom
von
Nachbarn also wir haben den Ausstieg
falsch organisiert würde ich mal sagen
und wir die ganze Klimageschichte hängt
ja daran dass wir Gaskraftwerke bauen im
Übergang ja und das finden wir und das
ist jetzt ins Wasser gefallen und jetzt
steht man da und sagt man die ganze der
ganze Transformation zu Klimaneutralität
hängt an um an den Gaskraftwerk müssen
neue gebaut werden
und wenn die Russen den haben das ist
vorbei dann ist es vorbei dann gehen wir
auch am Kohlekraftwerke wie pervers ist
es eigentlich ausgerechnet von den
Grünen dann die Kohlekraftwerke wieder
zu reaktivieren oder die jetzigen
einfach laufen zu lassen wenn man doch
so den Klimaschutz so hoch hält den
co2-ausschuss mein ich es mir neu dass
ein Atom Maler CO2 ist das tun die
Kohlekraft aber aber
nicht gesprochen wird ist nicht falsch
wenn sie mal geschaut haben auf die
tagesordnungsparlament es gab in den
letzten Wochen verschiedenster Anträge
zum Thema in Ausschüssen für das zu
diskutiert das Thema wurde durchaus
diskutiert und behandelt aber
eine Thema mit dem Uran das haben die
selber angesprochen mit dem brennstreben
das zweite Thema ist die Sicherheit also
alle sicherheitsgenehmigung für die
Atomkraftwerke laufen aus und ist die
letzten fünf Jahre nicht investiert
worden das heißt müsste erstmal
investiert werden da müsste eine neue
Abnahme erfolgen denn ich glaube keiner
will ohne abgenommene Sicherheit möchten
Sie ohne abgenommene
sicherheitsatomkraftwerke in Deutschland
laufen haben und man muss es nachholen
ist und auch der Müll jetzt mal ich also
sorgfältig prüfen ich freue mich Herr
Bremer dass sie das so ansprechen weil
ja es ist irgendwo ein trotzdem noch so
ein bisschen Tabu auch in der
median-darstellung aber in einer solchen
Krisensituation wo die Preise für
Energie explodieren und die Bürger sind
quasi nicht mehr zahlen und die Leute in
den Ratschlag geben ihr sollt frieren
und sowas da kann es doch nicht sein
dass wir die die laufen und
funktionieren dass man nicht in der Lage
ist und die treiberamt inzwischen ja
auch eingeräumt dass es geht dass man
neue Sicherheitskontrollen macht und
wenn es geht die noch mal drei vier
Jahre laufen lässt das produziert nicht
sehr dass das aber wir müssen es halt
nachgucken
getätigt werden ne stimmt doch also
ich bin einmal Herr bremerhain ja alt
ich habe ein ganz fatales Gefühl das bei
diesem Beispiel auch bei anderen Dinge
die man eigentlich politisch nicht so
gern will aus Rücksicht auf irgendwen in
diesem Fall also auf die Grünen und die
deshalb tabuisiert ist da bestreitet man
die Tabuisierung und sagt wir
diskutieren das ja in Ausschüssen und
das geht da auch hin und her und dann
kommt plötzlich die ganzen
Gegenargumente und das Thema ist wieder
weg sie diskutieren es nicht mit dem
Ziel es möglich zu machen sondern
möglichst unmöglich zu machen und das
ist eine unverantwortliche Haltung bei
einem Thema das jetzt den Nägeln brennt
wollen sie verantworten glauben Sie
wirklich dass die Deutschen alle noch so
toll dafür sind dass wir alles Mögliche
für die Ukraine machen wenn Sie das in
den nächsten Winter keinen Strom mehr
haben also erstmal Herr Bremer haben ein
riesiges entlast oder zwei riesiger
entlastungspakete aus dem Weg gebracht
bekommen und die erstmal die Bevölkerung
entlasten weil der Frau Strompreise
angesprochen
und der zweite Punkt
eine riesige Chance haben jetzt die
Energiewende voranzubringen jetzt mit
dem Frühjahrs im Sommer im herbstpaket
wirklich den die Klimawandel mit
Windenergie mit pv-energie
voranzubringen und dort wesentlich
unabhängiger zu werden und wesentlich
ambitionierter voranschreiten zu können
aber das je geplant hatten ich möchte
gerne stellen ein Herr Baum und zwar das
tabuti haben wir jetzt hier schon
aufgebrochen aber wer ist eigentlich zu
grün wenn man das mal so ausdrücken will
die Presse oder die Politik also wie
kommt denn eigentlich diese Entwicklung
beides ja ich habe eben hat der Bremer
ja die Kritik kritisiert der ganzen
letzten Jahre und sagt das hat ja jemand
anders reagiert also ich bitte die
Öffentlichkeit auch mal sich an die
eigene Nase zu passen wo waren denn die
Themen ja zum Beispiel in Bayern lese
ich da werden keine Überlandleitung
genehmigt seit Jahren nicht sie kriegen
den Windstrom nicht von Norden und dass
das weil weil die Bevölkerung dagegen
ist wir sind in Nordrhein-Westfalen
beispielsweise zugepflastert mit diesen
Dingern ja sie also und es gibt jetzt
ist eine augenblicksituation wo sich die
meint wo die Meinung kippen aber die
öffentliche Meinung die Meinung die auch
angestoßen werden müsste von den Medien
war auch nicht da wo war denn die
Diskussion über die Art Atomenergie
vorher na die ist ja jetzt auch nicht da
kommen recht wenn sie sagen ich möchte
eine zielorientierte Politik ich gehe
aber ich bin bei Ihnen wenn Sie sagen so
einfach ist das nicht ein Kernkraftwerk
mit einer neuen Genehmigung zu versehen
ich das wird ganz schwierig aber es ist
nicht ausgeschlossen möglicherweise
wenn man will kann man eine Menge
erreichen
wenn das bis Ende des Jahres im Griff
haben denn da laufen die ja letztens
erst aus noch ein Wort nur ganz also
wenn sie den Leuten sagen wenn so ein
Ding in die Luft geht dann werden sich
alle zurückschrecken und werden sagen
nee nee dann lieber nicht ne ne
sie haben die damals genehmigt weil sie
wussten die deutschen Meiler sind mit
die sichersten nicht ob sie heute noch
so sind nicht das weiß ich nicht bei uns
ist kein Tsunami bei uns ist kein
Fukushima das waren
stimmungsentscheidungen dieser Koalition
an der auch leider die FDP beteiligt war
nämlich mit Guido Westerwelle eine der
unglücklichsten Entscheidungen die da
getroffen worden sind das war falsch
aber Unglück 1 atomisch
den ich feststelle bei der Diskussion
der Ampel Konzept nicht nur den Eindruck
das war dann gesagt wird wir diskutieren
aber wir diskutieren so dass etwas gar
nicht stattfinden kann ich habe auch den
Eindruck dass man jetzt zunehmend den
ukraine-konflikt und die damit
verbundenen energiesorgen die wir haben
nutzt um sagen und jetzt muss man noch
schneller den in die Energiewende
betreiben den Klimawandel vorantreiben
ich sage nur in dem osterpaket von Herrn
Harbeck steht eine Zielsetzung für die
Vollversorgung mit Ökostrom 2035 im
Koalitionsvertrag den habe ich nämlich
gelesen steht 2045 jetzt hat die Ampel
sich geeinigt das Ding kommt ein
Bundestag es ist wie jetzt beim Impfen
jetzt soll der Bundestag die Lage also
wir wollen weil die Ampel untereinander
gehen
CO2-neutral in Deutschland bis 2045 sein
und bis 2035 soll der Strom zweimal im
Koalitionsvertrag so Erhalt bitte lesen
kurze Ergänzung wir finden das ja auch
gut wenn wenn gewiss durch eure Umstände
der Druck wächst und das beschleunigt
wird aber Sie können es halt nicht wenn
sie brauchen wenn sie Heizungen
austauschen sie kriegen doch im Moment
also ich kann es aus eigener Erfahrung
sagen in dem Jahr gibt es keinen der mir
bereitet wir haben ungefähr zehn
angefragt in dem Jahr gibt es keinen der
bereit ist die Heizung auszutauschen die
Handwerker sind völlig überlastet die
Leute wollen es man kann diese Krise so
bitter es ist sozusagen Nutzen für eine
anstehende Transformation aber Sie
werden es nicht von heute auf morgen
hinkriegen da haben sie einfach die
Handwerker nicht das dauert mehrere
Jahre und deshalb wäre dieser
vorschlagen jetzt in der Tinte also man
muss ja wirklich sagen wir sitzen jetzt
gerade energiepolitisch absolut in der
Tinte und es waren ja auch schon
Verbände vor Blackouts also ich bin da
ehrlich gesagt bei Herr Bremer da muss
man doch jetzt alles möglich machen was
irgendwie so CO2 Budget ja was wir jetzt
in die Luft geben bleibt ewig da über
unser Leben hinaus also wenn wir jetzt
verantwortungsvoll handeln müssen haben
wir nur noch einen geringen sp natürlich
auch lange gebraucht um das zu begreifen
also das heißt wir müssen die
Transformation schaffen auch jetzt unter
verschwerten Bedingungen und wir müssen
den Krieg schaffen der kostet ja wird
uns sehr viel kosten wir sind wir werden
in eine wir werden in eine enge kaum
auch mit unseren lebenshaltungssoft wir
werden Wohlstandsverlust haben das muss
nur den Bevölkerung gesagt werden das
sind ja 100 Aufgaben die klimagerichte
ist eine Jahrhundertaufgabe und ich also
Herr Bremer ich habe das nicht im Einzel
studiert aber was der Habeck da am Ziel
vorlegt der ist meines Erachtens nicht
unverknüpft denn er erblendet doch die
ökonomische Notwendigkeit die dir damit
verbunden sein muss und auch die
sozialen Aspekte nicht aus ich sage sie
würden als Union
es gibt Nachteile
ich habe ja gesagt wir unterstützen den
Transformationsprozess nur wir werden
ihn halt nicht von heute auf morgen
geschnippt lösen oder und deshalb ist
und auch das Paket ist eine Familie mit
zwei Kindern 800 € eine 800 €
Erleichterung davon für zwei
Arbeitnehmer und zwei Kinder also 2 x
300 und 2 x 200
Tankstelle letzte Woche der jetzt vorher
für 4500 Liter waren es vorher zwei fünf
ist jetzt für 1500 2000 €, also wissen
Sie was ich meine wir haben fast eine
für dreifachung des Öltanks Familien
haben auch oft alte Häuser da gibt es
oft noch eine Ölheizung also Öl irgendwo
aussprechen
wir können als Staat nicht alle Krisen
dieser Welt querfinanzieren wir können
den Schock abfangen den Schock dieser
Preissteigerung und das müssen wir auch
tun
50 Leute weniger als 1500 € Monat netto
also ich weiß was es heißt wenn Leute
wenig Geld haben das sind die meisten
meiner Wähler und da bin ich auch sehr
hinterher dass da auch was getan wird
und da bin ich auch sehr froh dass wir
die drei Monate Schritt Ermäßigung an
Tankstelle erreicht haben über die
Senkung der Mineralölsteuer auf das
eu-minimum aber wir können das nicht auf
die dauerfinanzieren und wenn sie sagen
immer mehr mehr mehr wir brauchen noch
mehr Entlastung sie wissen ganz genau
selber aus dem Haushalt die Spielräume
dafür nicht sind das ist nicht
finanzierbar ist
unterstellt Punkt
im Prinzip stimmt es ja auch der
Finanzminister sagt ja zu Recht der
Staat kann nicht alles abfedern das ist
völlig richtig aber machen Sie dann den
Leuten auch wirklich klar was es heißt
wenn das nicht möglich ist wir leben
eigentlich in einer Zeit der Vollkasko
Mentalität unter anderem auch durch 16
Jahre immer mal wieder große Koalition
ein bisschen mitgeprägt die Leute denken
die Sicherheit ist gut der hilft mir der
kann das jetzt nicht der kann nicht 100
Milliarden Mal für die Bundeswehr locker
machen was dringend notwendig ist damit
die mal wert sportlich wird der kann
nicht alles andere auch noch abfedern
ich wette mit ihnen wenn sie die klare
brutale Wahrheit sagen den Bürgern dann
ist das mit der Zustimmung zu vielem
nicht mehr so dolle die aber Sie müssen
sie eben sagen
okay wo ich bei ihnen bin wir müssen es
sozial abfedern also ich meine diese wir
haben nach dem Kriege das weiß kaum
jemand wir haben Lastenausgleich gehabt
ja wir haben übrigens die Besitzenden
haben die Hälfte abgegeben das plädiere
jetzt nicht dafür aber wir kommen eine
Situation wo wir ganz andere Lasten
verkraften Herr Baum sie haben ja
rechtliche Leuten sagen sie kennen das
bestimmt noch vom Nachtjournal da gab es
wahrscheinlich auch Unterbrechung wir
haben eine ganz kurze und dann sind wir
gleich wieder direkt zurück wir müssen
natürlich Geld verdienen ist völliga
wir sind gleich wieder zurück